and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today Ryan we're gonna talk
about raising kids I love talking about
raising kids when I don't have any
children myself so easy to give advice
we're talking about the data behind good
parenting and we're gonna talk about how
parents can be more confident in their
parenting decisions and we're gonna do
that with today's guests
Emily oyster from Brown University is
here emily is the author of two books
one is expecting better which is when
there was a book about pregnancy and
then once you're done being pregnant you
actually have to raise the kids it's
true yes so we have her next book here
her newest book is called crib sheet a
data-driven guide to better more relaxed
parenting from birth to preschool what a
good book it's I love how it's like a
it's a great reference book for every
almost every subject you can think of
when it comes to raising a child my hope
for the YouTube audience who's watching
this if you're listening at home you
can't see it but it's a beautiful cover
and it's a it's a really good book I was
actually reading this book in the
hospital last week my six-year-old was
in the hospital having a surgery that
was planned and I was in there and
everyone was calling on me and and so
I'm getting over a cold myself and I was
telling Emily before we started
recording it I I really wish I would
have had this six years ago it would
have been really helpful it was my
parents would have had it 38 years ago
now this is a listener driven show so
let's dive into some questions here our
first question today is from Beth in
Arlington Virginia hi Ryan and Josh I am
Beth from Arlington Virginia I am
finally at a stable place in my personal
and professional life after being in
school for 25 straight years and
completing four degrees including my
doctorate last year my family and
friends keep asking when are you going
to get married and what about having
kids I put vegetation of the priority in
my life and now that I am done I
remember the warmer
if one day I do get married and if we
decide to have kids I'm struggling with
which partner will have to sacrifice
their career to help raise the family
although I live a minimal and joy driven
lifestyle I had invested 25 years and
over $400,000 in tuition and student
loans to obtain a great job where I save
lives every day do you have any advice
on making sacrifices to raise a family
and if the mother doesn't want to give
up her career what should they support
of spouse dude in return so Emily you're
an economist your husband's also an
economist right okay so I imagine we
walk into your house it's just like
spreadsheets everywhere like your
children has to do something you're like
there's not enough data to support that
decision I'm sorry lists our family is
like really into checklist do you want
to go to your friend's house give me a
checklist we'll go over it Frank show me
the data and if it makes sense yeah you
can go over to your friend's house I did
tell my girl the other day like she said
I want to have the following change in
my in my like something I have
permission to do and I was like that's
great why don't you write up a proposal
for like how we will how we will do that
but she to be fair she hasn't done that
like oh forget it fine but I think there
is like there is an advantage to raising
your kids that way to kind of help them
just think about things in a in a very
different way instead of going on a
motion I mean the kids are they're
really good on acting on a motion but
kind of doing that hope some kind of act
off of some reasoning I guess so what
let's talk to Beth here about you she
mentioned sacrifices she mentioned and I
think that's true yeah we always have to
make saccharides
is a sacrifice self I think Emily would
call it an opportunity cost absolutely
and so let's talk about some of those
sacrifices but also finding a partner
because you're really the term
co-parenting generally means like
parents have split up and and now
they're they're raising kids separately
but we I mean my wife and I and our
six-year-old daughter we're co-parenting
because we're parenting together right
yeah I mean I think sort of thinking
about what Beth said
there was an underlying part of that
question which somehow presumed that if
she does choose to have kids that she
will somehow somebody will have to give
up something about their career and that
it will it will sort of have to be her
that that would be the the default and I
think there is a sense in which when you
have a kid like that's something else
you have to you have to do and it's sort
of silly to pretend that there aren't
going to be sacrifices or there aren't
going to be that that isn't going to
take time that you would be doing from
from other things but I also think I I
would not want people to go into this
thinking you know if I'm a woman and I
have a kid that's gonna be it for all
this investment I made in my in my
career because there are ways to manage
that and one of the things I talk about
in the book is you know what does the
evidence say about having two parents
work versus somebody stay home and the
evidence says that those are both fine
in terms of your kids outcomes that your
kids do sort of similarly well with two
parents working or one parent working
and one parent not and so that doesn't
have to be a choice that if I decide to
have a kid I'm going to decide not to
have a job although I think it's fair to
think about you know the kid is gonna
require some time and energy and you're
gonna need to think about how you how
you managed that and how you manage it
with both with both parents yeah I
totally agree like you don't to choose
one or the other I think something I
would tell Beth here also is what she
mentioned her priority and like how you
know school and her job is her priority
so what are her priorities get clear on
that and when you're looking for a
partner express what those priorities
are and you have to find a partner who's
willing to support you and your
priorities and vice versa also
preferences I know emily in your book
you talk about preferences quite a bit
and in a lot of these decisions they
come down to incorporating preferences
with the data as opposed to just like
well i here's what the data says but if
the data is gonna make you miserable
then then that alone isn't going to give
you the answer that you want yeah i
think also the game of the whole family
that is another in some ways another
message of the book is that is that a
lot of these parenting decisions the way
that we frame them in the popular
discourse are just what is best for the
baby and what are the things we're going
to do to enhance our baby and make it
the best baby
you know that and like and almost like
any amount of sacrifice by parents is
okay in even if it's a tiny big good for
the for the baby and I think that's not
a super helpful way to think about it
because of course parents being happy
and feeling fulfilled and feeling like
they have agency is also an important
part of having your family function
correctly and function well and I think
that's also good for them for the baby
because also if raising your kid is
making you a ball of anxiety that
anxiety is going to certainly rub off on
on the kid yeah if you're exhausted and
you like and you're not sleeping and you
can barely drive and function at your at
your job or in your household that's
probably also not good for your kid yeah
yeah you said the word sacrifice and it
makes me think like when you have kids
there's gonna be some sacrifices right I
mean am I wrong on that you've got to
figure out what you are willing to
sacrifice with best situation she wants
to put her job first which is totally
cool but she is sacrificing some time
spent with the kid so I think yeah I
mean get clearing less priorities and
figure out what you're willing to
sacrifice what your partner is willing
to sacrifice is I mean there's no way to
not have sacrifices and parenting is
that what you think I think I think
that's there they're always going you're
going to give up something in order to
get something right and so if that's
what we mean by sacrifice or opportunity
cost however I do think there is a weird
sort of societal double standard where
women are expected to do everything it's
you are supposed to be the best
stay-at-home mom who also has a 50 hour
a week a prestigious career with a
couple of super moms well III don't know
I mean it in and and so Emily can we
talk a little bit about that because I
don't see that that same double standard
for men where like we're supposed to be
out Stan I mean the definition of an
outstanding father is often one who is a
a career driven father whereas an
outstanding mother has to have sort of
both components yeah I mean I think a
lot of women there is cuvee a double
center and you see it all over the place
you see when you travel with your kids
you know if you travel alone with your
six-year-old probably now that he's now
that they're older it's a little
different but when you view it like a
guy traveling alone with a baby
oh my gosh you're so travelling giving
your wife
that's so great you see a woman
traveling on the baby people are like
great sitting next to a lady with the
baby on an airplane you know they and
and it means this it's this sort of like
like kind of what are your expectations
for how people will will behave you know
even if you're you're like the dad is
with the kids one day we may have a lot
of friends we're like they sort of split
the weekend and like you know one or at
least each person will get a little bit
of time to themselves on the weekend
where the other parent has the kids baby
would be like oh it's so great that
you're babysitting for your wife like
what would that mean like be like
babysit like it's your kid it's not
babysitting your kid like that so the
son what that is and so I think it's
hard and I think it makes it it makes it
harder for women to kind of navigate the
the having a career and having a kid
because the expectations that people
place on what is going to be an
acceptable amount of parenting are just
totally different Beth I'm gonna send
you a copy of Emily's new book crib
sheet I think you're gonna enjoy it
whenever the time comes for you to have
kids obviously you have a few other
steps in between there it's finding the
ideal partner right and then and then of
course setting those priorities as
expectations and equally important those
preferences and making sure you're
really clear Ryan and I we often talk
about finding someone whose values align
with ours even when our beliefs are
different so Ryan and I are a really
good example of this in terms of being
really good friends and and business
partners we have very similar values
core values foundational values but our
beliefs are pretty different we have
different political beliefs we have
different spiritual and religious
beliefs but there are different just
different paths that get us to those
those same values and so if you also
want to learn more about that you can
head over head on over to our podcast
episode number 69 we did a entire
podcast episode about the values but
we'll send you a copy of Emily's book
crib sheet our next question is from
Stephanie in Tampa Florida hi my name is
Stephanie I'm from Tampa Florida my
question is about family so my mom is a
hoarder in the truest sense of the word
hoarder she gets things from estate
sales as she doesn't need and just keep
them in her house
and says that one day they will be me
and my sister's problem when she passes
away so my question is with her with
someone that has the mindset of I'm just
getting things just to get things and me
trying to go down the minimalist path
that I'm trying to go down I have a
two-year-old and my mother is starting
to try to instill into my daughter this
mindset of just getting things just to
have them so my daughter goes to my
mom's house she came out his stuff and
wondering why we don't have all this
stuff at home so I guess my question is
how do I get my mom who is clearly a
hoarder to understand that I'm trying to
instill in my daughter a minimalism
lifestyle or a lifestyle where she
doesn't feel like she needs things just
to fill her life so Emily when we talk
about minimalism we're really talking
about intentional consumption of the
bringing in goods that add value to our
lives they enhance or augment our
experience of life Ryan and I are not
against material possessions we are
against material possessions they get in
the way of living a meaningful or
purposeful life now what Stephanie is
asking here with her mom is hey my mom
and I don't have the same values and
what I'm worried about is my mom is
going to instill values that I think are
detrimental to my kid now that through
through her lenses consumption but that
can be that could really be anything I'm
tensed always say what does the data say
about this but but what but in terms of
like I'm sure you you've stumbled across
in the research there are there are new
mothers and new fathers who have parents
whose values they don't want to instill
in their their children yeah and I think
it comes up a lot I mean this is an it's
an interesting example because I think
many people have a form of what of what
she's describing with with stuff you
know maybe not as Extreme as you know my
mom is a hoarder but in the
space of you know my the grandparents
give my kid gifts that I don't look too
much stuff and I'm trying not to have so
much so much stuff and I think you know
part of it is it's very hard to regulate
your it's very hard to regulate your
parents when it comes to your like any
some it's like mostly it you might not
not be able to do that but you can try
to instil you know values and your kid
particularly as they're older it's hard
with the two-year-old you know but with
the with an older kid
they are I think they're more capable
than we give them credit for for
understanding the idea that you know
people are gonna differ in the choices
that they that they make and there are
reasons we make these choices and so
even with you know with kids who are you
know my kids are four and eight but
they're you know they're all the ones
old enough to understand like you know
we don't want to consume we don't want
to just buy things to have them because
like that's not nice for the earth or
whatever you know whatever is the sort
of particular reason for your for your
values and I think we sometimes don't
give kids enough credit for the idea
that they can understand that people
could have different values and that you
know our family is trying to have a
particular kind of you know kind of
value yeah yeah helping the kid wake
understand the benefits of having less
helping them understand the harmful
things of having more and help you I
totally agree like a kid can grasp that
that information yeah I think that that
there are a few things that come to mind
when I'm well if I were talking to
Stephanie first thing that I would would
say is instead of telling your your mom
what you don't want her to do because
that doesn't work how well mom I don't
want you to do this anymore
isn't it interesting like I think about
trying to regulate your parents it's
like your parents trying to regulate you
as a teenager exactly like it it's it's
it's funny because we grow up hating
being regulated but then we go out of
the house and then we're like oh now
we're gonna try and regulate our parents
I think it's like trying to fill this
cup with oxygen right it's like well
we're not going to blow into it like
it's still it's it's still an empty cup
sort of thing the the thing I'm thinking
about though with was Stephanie's mom is
telling the parents what you do want as
opposed to what you what you don't want
yeah Ryan talked about the benefits
knowing the why behind the values is
really important but instead of going
hey mom stop doing this stop
stop putting stuff in front of her stop
giving her things yeah tell her what to
give her give her examples of
experiences or things that will actually
bring value instead of trying to fill
the cup up with air fill it with
something that is is nourishing yeah why
and I think like when she's having a
talk with her mom like stephanie has to
put everything she can on herself like
instead of saying you know your house
you do this you do that they don't call
her a hoarder right exactly like that's
yeah so it's well it's funny cuz I was
thinking when I first heard this voice
mail I always think to myself like what
is you know an example beside the
example given like what else can we kind
of liken this to and I thought about
what if her mother was a chain smoker
she smoked in the house constantly and
there was secondhand smoke always in the
house a great example I quote would
Stephanie do she probably would would
keep her child out of that unsafe
environment as much as possible this
isn't really too unlike that I mean
especially you know some of the hoard
recorders you've got stacks of paper I
mean it is truly an unsafe situation yes
there's a pit the answer here a hoarding
is the new second-hand smoking I can
tweet that podcast Sean yeah yeah so
it's like you know you want to explain
to your mother in the most loving way
putting everything you can on yourself
that you really can't have your child
around an unhealthy environment and
that's what her mother is providing
right now is an unhealthy environment it
doesn't mean that you know the mother
her mother can't see her granddaughter
but certainly again if she was a
second-hand smoker I know that I would
keep my grandma's us she's a secondhand
smoke she's a smoker
like my grandma smokes a lot I would
keep my child out of her house as much
as possible because I wouldn't want my
kid inhaling that secondhand smoke I
know ultimately you have to love someone
from a distance you have to set up some
boundaries here and I think the example
you you bring up is so poignant because
it it really illustrates how harmful
some behaviors can be now obviously
there's a media not even an immediate I
mean it was smoking it's not a media
right there's a long-term sort of health
effect there so so Emily did one
to setting boundaries I know that we can
talk about setting boundaries for our
kids but also setting boundaries for the
people who are in our kids lives is
important I mean I and I think that's a
place where where it's it's valuable to
sort of think about distinguishing
between like things that are that we
think of as dangerous right so you sort
of said like secondhand smoke you know
like fire hazard kind of unsanitary
conditions as a thing where like I can't
like it is not safe for me to expose my
kid you know if you had a relative who
is who would drove under the influence
like you wouldn't put the kid in the car
with them there's like things there
where there's a line and then there are
things where it's like that isn't my
preference but that isn't the way I
would do it and I think that sometimes
when in the sort of like hyper tense
world of modern parenting you can get
really into sort of like well my hit kit
this is the routine that we have you
know and like this is a routine in my
house my kid has to practice or violin
at this time and I have to do this at
this time and they have to like we don't
let them have carbohydrates for snack
you know which like to be fair is a rule
that I have in my house like we have
their snacks you're not allowed to have
carbohydrates for snack at home I don't
know that's just a rule they don't eat
as much lunch it's that's what we came
up with but I think I have had to let go
a little bit like when they're my mom's
house
you know she gives them carbohydrates
for an accident give him candy for snack
but you know sometimes they have
crackers and like you have to you have
to see in your in your parenting where
what is the like crackers for snack and
what is the secondhand smoke and and
recognize and I think this can be harder
than it then it seems to recognize them
you know your kid is gonna have an
independent relationship with with your
parents or with other people in in your
lives and and that that you can you can
explain you know we have a particular
set of rules or values and there are
some which are so important that we're
going to enforce them on other people
and some which are the way that our
family operates but there are many other
good ways to operate and you know when
you're at Grandma's house it's okay to
have crackers you have to let it go you
gotta let it go a little not my best
thing so that's what I mean that's where
Stephanie's out right now like she has
to really make that decision yeah
is this at the level she's like it's I
have to draw the line you can't see your
your grandkid as much or is it the level
of you know it's okay to do but I want
to make sure I explain to my kid as they
get older why we uh Pro operate our
family different
and then I'd be a middle ground where
maybe she avoids the house you know a
little bit more than what she has and
makes plants outside of bow so do you
think so I mean there might be a middle
ground there where yeah she doesn't
completely suck one grandmas but she
maybe decreases the time that her
daughter spends there I had a well two
things one is I think for Stephanie she
has the leverage and she has to realize
she has the leverage here and if he
wants to sell kid
it is the time with the kid for sure
right and and so approaching it in a
positive manner like you talked about
not going to saying you're a hoarder and
I can't have the second-hand hoarding
around my that's a good thing like a
good book title they're secondhand
hoarding but I can't have I can't my kid
around this this there's there's a
better way to approach it in a positive
manner where you're putting your
preferences on it but also this past
week I had one of those situations where
I did have to let go some stuff we were
in the hospital of all places ironically
and after Ella's surgery she's sitting
there in the recovery room and they
bring her like some food to II had the
do a morning fast beforehand which is
impossible for a six-year-old to do no
two-hour fast and afterward though that
they brought her this food after she
comes to and it's like jello and a bunch
of crackers and they saw we'll bring
some chicken soup chicken noodle soup
that it was really just pasta with a
little bit of like chicken broth in it
and and like it was not it's the epitome
of like what we wouldn't give her in our
own house but it's like okay this is a
one-time thing it's in the hospital
we're trying to get her some nourishment
this is this the best food no is it the
best option right now yeah I'm not gonna
ask her after her surgery you know
you're gonna have to continue to fast
because I don't want you to have to
saltine crackers what a great question
is this the best option yeah so like
anytime that her daughter is going over
there like that's the question should be
asking is is this the best option right
now
Stephanie i'ma send you a copy of our
book essential there are twelve
different chapters in that book it's an
essay collection 150 different essays
about intentional living twelve
different areas of intentional living
and one of those areas has to do with
our stuff how can we consume things
more intentionally and so we're talking
about stuff we're talking about hoarding
we're talking about minimalism Stephanie
I think you'll find a lot of value in
that stuff chapter and the other 11
chapters as well if you like our podcast
you'll like the audiobook version of
that book or if you want the e-book or
the book book we're happy to send those
to you as well Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it it's time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media
now Emily here's what we do we're at the
minimalists on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
what you're at Prof Emily Oster there we
go on Twitter you could fall over there
we'll put a link to all of the stuff
we're talking about today in the show
notes as well
now Emily Emily here's what we try to do
we we try to answer questions with short
shareable less than 140 character
responses not 280 characters well no
we're minimalist but not really
we just we Mandar on quite a bit and
then Sean liked wheezes something out in
post it makes it look beautiful he puts
it in the show notes so people can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if they like and also our friend
Jessica who manages all the social media
she she puts all of our minimal Maxim's
in one place now it's minimal Maxim's
com
Ryan what's our questions that our first
question is for ya her question today is
Danielle what's the best way to educate
children in a world filled with
consumerism
so Emily we are bombarded with messages
the stat I used to use was three to five
thousand advertising messages a day I
saw a stat recently that said up to ten
thousand my guess is that's poor people
in New York and LA probably so
advertising to kids nowadays more than
ever more than ever yeah and and by the
way when we're kids I think we're that's
when we're most susceptible to it I mean
I think we're very susceptible
susceptible to it now even as the
minimalist side see a Rolex and I won't
want even though I don't wear a watch
yeah
what am i doing so so how do you think
we're Danielle's kid we should just send
her a three of our books so her Kate can
read our books
she can educate her child here read
these minimalism books how do we educate
our children to to make them more
conscious of their consumption I would
say talk to them about people who have
less to the extent that age
I mean I think I found with my kids
that's the that is the thing that has in
some ways been the most effective is to
talk about there are you know there are
people who don't have anything and not
in a way that you know you should feel
guilty but in a way that you know when
we consume when we consume that you can
live with with less stuff and that when
we consume this stuff it is it can be
wasteful and also putting things in
perspective because a kids perspective
is they're sort of all children are
solipsistic
and so their worldview is literally
their view like what they see around
them it's it's like it's vaguely occult
actually like there's this as a kid you
almost feel like the entire world was
constructed for you and as you leave the
room everything just sort of dissipates
and as you re into the world or the room
the world re materializes to your point
of view and helping them understand
these other worldviews whether it is
working at a soup kitchen or it's it's
yeah taking them to Goodwill when L we
take her once a month to go donate stuff
we'll have a donation bag but don't just
show her the the action we we explained
to her and try to help her understand
where the things are going and now she
explains to us where they're going and I
find that important my pithy answer is
minimalism is not a way to escape
consumption it's a way to consume
responsibly and and I think really
that's what we're talking about here we
talk about asking the right questions
you're Ryan and I we we have the the
five questions we ask before buying
anything new or we have set up some
rules that that we each have excuse me
that when we're trying to bring
something new into our life or we're
trying to hold on to something we do so
in a deliberate way and and I think
quite often people get confused about
minimalism or simplifying or parenting
even and thinking there are definitive
answers and I think Emily what you do
really well here is you you I mean you
give some definitive answers where it
really makes sense but sometimes it's
like well half the parents circumcise
their kids the
they're half don't write and you get the
you know net it's really up to your
preference sort of thing yeah yeah my
pet the answer is similar what you were
talking about earlier Josh children
learn more from conduct than counseling
so you know if a parent is trying to
raise their kids right they need to be
raising themselves right and that's
really where kids are gonna learn I mean
it's you know there's 50% nursery or 50%
nature I guess or whatever percentage
that works out to be with with kids
isn't it more like ninety ten is it yeah
it's it's almost all nature right like
we're pretty much screwed from birth I
mean I think you can see you know people
can look at like twin studies and see
sort of how much two twins didn't do
twins share but you know I don't I don't
it's yeah yeah actually it makes me
Theravada nurture it makes me think of
what's a documentary called well the
three the triplets like found each other
and everything where they were all like
yeah that was cool but like they were it
was I feel like they were all the same
person
well I feel like it was 50% the same but
then they all had their 50% differences
but now but none of them were like well
one has neck tattoos and and the other
ones in prison and the other one with
the preference is president in the
United States but the preferences of
behaviors were a little bit different
yeah I don't know I don't know what the
I don't know I need to see the data to
back up ninety ninety ten Josh when you
it's true when you have two kids it's
you becomes very quickly clear that like
a lot of the differences are just at
Birth adverse like you basically sort of
immediately like my son is way like
calmer person than my daughter and not
like they're they're great and there's a
lot of things that are very similar but
you could just sort of see it like that
he was just like a little bit less
high-strung and that was true it like
two weeks you know yeah yeah all right
before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week indeed we do let's
check out some of these questions here
how can a parent help motivate their
children to engage with their
surroundings instead of pacifying
themselves with phones and tablets and
glowing screens
what are Emily's tips for a
gifted children what about her tips for
special-needs children what are some
financial education resources for
children and also a bunch more questions
here like should you breastfeed should
you Sleep Train
what are Emily's three biggest parenting
surprises thoughts on helicopter
parenting and I'm gonna ask her whether
or not all children or sociopaths Ryan
we've got about three million other
parenting questions for Emily and I want
to argue with her that uh having
children I think might be a bad decision
I'm gonna have her talk me out of it or
maybe she'll talk me into it who knows
and if you wanna hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
much longer maximal episode on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about topics we don't usually discuss in
public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists comm slash support
Ryan what else you got for us this week
you know y'all if all you are doing or
listening to Josh and I and what we have
to say you're really doing yourself a
disservice so you got to read more you
got to get informed you can do that this
week with this book right here that I'm
holding up to the camera if you're
watching this on YouTube with Emily
Oscars crib sheet I was like it's a crib
sheet parenting or just crib sheet crib
sheet you know what this book man it's
it's a great reference book it's crazy
though you you know the argument about
having kids or not I think analytically
the answer is no like no you should not
have kids but emotionally it's like
that's where I want to have kids but
it'll be interesting to see what she has
to say about that and then of course
I've got some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi my name is Erin and I live in Salt
Lake City and first off I wanted to
thank you all the minimalist team for
your podcast it continually helps me
simplify my life and to recognize that
simplicity and minimalism is a journey
and not a destination as something
I have to continually work at um during
the clothing episode you touch a lot on
intentional purchasing and I had a tip
I've been using lately that I hope can
help other listeners Express
intentionality when they need to buy
thing so I do they keep a note on my
phone of questions that I have to aunt
look at an answer before I purchase
something and it can be anything from
groceries to clothing and you can come
up with whatever questions were free but
here mine is an example so the first one
is and hopefully it's the podcast
favorite does this add value to my life
the second one can I afford it the third
can something else do the same job or
substitute well enough so hopefully it
forces me to be a little bit creative
and see if I can find something already
that will work for us we'll use it
frequently enough to warrant buying it
so it helps me consider if it's
something that maybe I can borrow or
rent instead the fifth can i buy it used
if I do need to buy it and then the
sixth does it fall in line with my
principles so for instance I'm a vegan
for ethical reasons so I want to buy
food issues to buy plant-based food this
is clothing it's something that I
hopefully can find sustainably produced
and that will last me a long time or if
it has any type of packaging that
hopefully it's recyclable and then
lastly which kind of ties back to the
first one do I need it or do I just want
it and if it's something I just want and
it needs to go back on the shelf
digestion right my name is Chris Urban
and I'm a computer tech calling in from
Chico California I was listening to your
organizing episode and wanted to give a
tip to Tanya who called in wanting to
sort her digital file you guys mentioned
cloud storage is an option which is
great for some I personally dislike
cloud storage because I never want to
risk my personal privacy if there was a
security issue with the cloud service
I'll be facing sorting my own digital
files as Leung will be doing it with two
hard drives which will be the same model
of ties and will be in raid one without
going into too much detail raid one is a
way to set up hard drives to be mirror
images of each other every time a file
is added to one it goes to the other
also it appears as a onedrive in the
operating system if one drive fails the
other will still have the data it's a
great way to backup important data and
avoid the cloud I realize this sounds
very complicated but it really isn't
search online for how to set up raid 1
and I am sure you will find plenty of
guides all right Joe thanks again to
Emily for joining us today check out her
latest book crib sheet you can also
check out her first book about pregnancy
it is called expecting better and real
quick 4 right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist actually I've got
two things for you if you want to follow
lol on Twitter she's at Ellis and which
she says the craziest things we'll get
into that a little bit more on the
maximum up so talk about Ella and her
thousands of Twitter followers but it's
a it's almost a scrapbook or a diary of
all the things she has said for the last
I don't know five years or so three
years for you or something like that and
also we've been doing this thing with
these wallpapers now we have a growing
list of wallpapers to help people
declutter they're glowing screens so
whether it's your smartphone or your
computer if you go to the minimalists
comm slash wallpapers you can find our
love people use things wallpaper that
one is really popular I've seen a lot of
people sharing it on Instagram social
media but also our personal favorite the
minus sign I think both of us have the
subtract sign on our phones what else do
we have it's a growing
we've got the scrolling is new smoking
that one should be out by the time this
episode comes out if not it'll be out
soon you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you
we've got lessons now we've got a bunch
of others coming so you can keep
checking back there
you just go to the minimalists comm /
wallpapers to download your free
minimalist wallpapers declutter your
glowing screens today at no charge and
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com / the minimalists and if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list and the
minimalists comm you also receive our
simple Sunday emails for our added value
this week I just discovered this this EP
by a group named sailor I don't know if
you've heard of them of course they
spell it all cool yeah it's it's like
spelled like a tech company or something
right yeah SI IL are you think like they
serve people sort of spelling things
that way because that's how they could
get domains and then because people
started spelling it that way all of a
sudden it became hip to start taking out
certain vowels yes and I also think it
has something to do with when you are
googling someone if they have a very
common like one of my favorite R&B
artists his name is black but he spells
it with a six instead of a being so
because you just google the word black
you're gonna get like I don't know a
some painting website will come up like
here's where you complied st. or a black
car and and so so it started out for
marketing purposes and now it's cool I
think so just like you Josh you should
put a six and Nicodemus Nicodemus all
right let's uh in this episode with a
song called heartbeat from sailor's new
EP it's called vol 2 and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time bye and minimus